[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
politique à table sur lcp vous
connaissez le principe on reçoit un
invité un homme ou une femme politique
autour d'un plat et d'un dessert qu'il a
lui-même choisi et cette semaine pour
présenter avec moi cette émission jean
pierre montaner bonjour bojic bonjour
oro berger bonjour et cette semaine
aurait vraiment comment berger bonjour
et bienvenue à vous vous êtes député la
république en marche des yvelines
présidente déléguée du groupe
majoritaire à l'assemblée
vous représentez on peut dire l'ailé
droite de la majorité vous adhérez à 16
ans à l'ump vous soutenez tour à tour
nicolas sarkozy alain juppé françois
fillon avant de vous rapprocher du
candidat mâcon c'est en 2010 est très
engagé sur les sujets culturels
vous défendez aussi le bien-être animal
ce qui ne vous empêche pas de ne pas
manger de viande n'est ce pas jean louis
avec un boeuf bourguignon un plat qui
annonce l'hiver idéal pour égayer nos
soirées en mode couvre-feu et en dessert
un gâteau qui exigent leur berger
l'excellence un moelleux au chocolat
dans les pieds dans le plat vous ne
direz comment enseigner la liberté
d'expression à l'école et comment
protéger les professeurs après
l'assassinât terroristes de
conflans-sainte-honorine dans le dos ou
des plats une pensée pour notre boeuf un
peu ton en finir avec l'élevage intensif
où nous sommes allés dans le morvan sur
une exploitation qui élèvent des porcs
en plein air
la belle vie quoi allez on passe à table
a tout de suite ses cuisines et
confidences
alors aux bergers vous en avais
ras-le-bol à ces étiquettes qui vous
colle à la peau un clivante opportuniste
à vous qui avez soutenu on l'a entendu
tour à tour sarkozy fillon et j'en passe
et maintenant emmanuel macron alors qu'à
table on en met alors qu'à table
question cuisine là vous jouez vraiment
la carte du consensus avec un plat très
fédérateur un bon vieux boeuf
bourguignon des familles alors dites moi
si je m'égare quand je dis ça ou si
c'est vraiment votre plat préféré
alors c'est l'un de mes plats préférés
parce que c'est un plat d'enfance c'est
un plat comme préparé et que continuer à
me préparer ma maman est donc c'est vrai
que c'est un m'a demandé de choisir un
plat c'est celui ci dit spontanément
mais m'est venu parce que c'est celui
qui évoque la chaleur de la famille
alors je vous le temps et puis vous
allez goûter avec nous le dire ci vous
rappelle votre en france loft voilà je
vous dirais des dents chez françoise 1
qui cuisine qui cuisine les plats je ne
sais pas si cuisine aussi bien que votre
maman vous allez nous le dira
c'est très beau les très beaux et les
faits dans les règles de l'art et ce
très bon c'est le bout que vous
reconnaissez vous que je reconnais
évidemment avec ses accompagnements
voilà évidemment avec les pâtes etc
donc oui mais c'est un je pense que
c'est un plat qui aiment les français
aussi c'est un pelage espèces il est
consensuel
parce que là aussi sur le terrain oui
battant ceux ci sont moins en moins
quand c'est moi j'aimerais conçue elle
est passée traditionnelles en matière
culinaire
ouais c'est vrai je suis pas une grande
expérimental on va dire ça comme ça
blanquette des choses comme ça mais là
c'est assez classique parce que c'est
tout simplement les plats aussi auxquels
j'ai pu être être habitué donc de l'osso
buco du boeuf carottes comme c'est pas
du boeuf bourguignon du pot-au-feu
lasson sont des plats qui sont surtout
dans cette période à la fois pas être
plus hivernal mais s'ils perdent ils
vont se faire sur place aussi mais
beaucoup nsa doit laisser sa place
réconfortant en fait je trouve là qui
font du bien ils sont réconfortants mais
pas trop téméraire exotiques
bon j'ai des méduses chinois lors
quasiment jamais
drenthe bombadil c'est plein de
protéines comme les ya plein de
protéines je préfère le boeuf aux
insectes et est ce que votre maman vous
à livrer sa recette est ce qu'il ya chez
vous la recette de mamans avec des
barras a devant elle est plutôt pour le
dessert qu'il a été vraiment transmis
mais qui est en fait que je n'ai pas le
droit de dévoiler voilà qu'il doit ré so
correctement du gâteaux chocolats mous
et le donc ça pour le coup il ya
interdiction de dévoiler quoi que ce
soit sur la manière avec laquelle maman
prépare à la recette maintenant je dois
le faire alors le boeuf bourguignon
d'autres mamans mais est ce que vous le
faites vous même est ce que aurore bergé
est aux fourneaux avec ses carottes
c'est toujours sympa creuse à dire
comment dire pas vraiment pas vraiment
qu'ils n'ont pour ainsi dire pas
apparaître de temps barbares dont deux
allemands en vrai par manque de temps
d'abord donc quand je le fais c'est
justement plutôt en famille entre amis
pendant les vacances ou là on est on est
un peu la main à la pâte on est
plusieurs
mais c'est vrai que au quotidien je dois
bien l'avouer je ne corresponds pas et
donc quand a été prononcée le
confinement
là j'ai dû y mettre fin lui de rester là
j'ai dû vraiment mieux mettre mais je
suis sûr d'être donc pour vous aimerez
aussi la nourriture ce campus dans les
yeux nous s'est il n'y a pas forcément
beaucoup de livraisons comme comme
appareil donc du coup mais je vois là je
me suis vous avez lancé vous vous êtes
lancé dans quoi par exemple c'est le
moment d'en parler c'est cette émission
est pourri les pets cd et des plats qui
s'accommode de plein de choses
les salades aussi donc voilà je mets ce
qu'on va tester non plus bonne chose que
canal très large au delà de des recettes
de cuisine et tout ça est ce que vous
aimez quand même le bon produit est ce
que ça vous fait réaliser
allez je vous y attends dimanche sur le
marché alors moi c'est surtout le samedi
tiens moi et puis surtout on a découvert
ou redécouvert surtout notamment moi
dans mon département tous les maraîchers
et toutes les fermes
on a à proximité donc à la fois ce qu'on
peut avoir sur son marché et puis
pendant toute là bas deux continents on
avait plus de marché mais vous pouvez
directement chez le producteur chez
l'exploitant notamment dans les
maraîchages donc j'ai fait comme
beaucoup de français j'ai pu aller aussi
me fournir directement chez les
producteurs et dans les fermes donc le
griot quand même c'est quelque chose que
vous regardez vous pouvez ou à des
petits circuits deçà des valeurs
circuits courts ça oui j'essaye vraiment
de le faire un peu par militantisme a
aussi local parce que je pense que c'est
important de faire vivre ce qui
travaille à proximité de chez nous et
qui travaille bien en plus mais après
bio quand c'est possible
et puis de toute façon même quand c'est
pas bio on a honnêtement une agriculture
de qualité en france je crois que les
français l'ont découvert ou redécouvert
justement pendant le confinement et donc
on peut s'alimenter de manière
enfin déjà à des prix qui sont
raisonnables dans notre pays ce qui
n'est pas toujours le cas et on peut
bien s'alimenter ce d'autant plus qu'en
cuisine en effet en allant au contact
des producteurs comme vous l'avez fait
prendre le confinement vous avez
découvert des choses des nouveaux
légumes des fruits
la chose que vous avez vous des
nouvelles façons de les préparer avec
ses producteurs
alors soyons honnêtes à mon niveau de
cuisine reste quand même assez assez
basique un jeu voilà j'ai pas
l'impression de vous mentir là dessus
vraiment jeu j'ai fait du basique mais
j'ai fait ce qui était déjà assez
nouveau pour moi mais non à ce qui était
indiqué intéressant encore une fois
c'est de voir la palette qu'ont acquis
extrêmement large
parce que moi j'ai la chance en tout cas
dans mon département en avoir et du
maraîchage et de l'élevage et aussi ceux
qui produisent leur pain enfin vraiment
on a on a cette culture là et on a de la
chance de l'avoir et donc je crois que
c'était important
vous nous dites j'aime les plats de mon
enfance et je continue à en manger
est ce que vous mangez autant de viande
qu'avant parce qu'aujourd'hui il ya
quand même cette pression sur la viande
sur le côté écologique haussier de
l'élevage alors j'ai pas arrêté de
manger
j'arrêterai pas de manger deux jambes
parce que j'aime ça tout simplement
c'est des dégoûts mois m'intéresse
notamment que soit le boeuf que soit le
port que soit le lapin enfin voilà des
aliments que j'aime après je pense qu'on
est tous de plus en plus soucieux à la
fois sur la quantité de viande quantité
de viande qu'on peut ou non consommée
c'est vrai qu'en france on en consomme
beaucoup et surtout le sur la qualité et
sur la traçabilité des produits qu'on
consomme ça je pense qu'on a tous pris
l'habitude quand on va chez le boucher
ou sur son marché se demander d'où ou a
été élevé la viande ou est ce qu'elle a
et éventuellement a battu fin dans
quelles sont les méthodes et c'est ça je
pense que la traçabilité
on est tous très attachés après je suis
pas devenu vegan donc à la fois je suis
très attaché à la question de bien-être
animal
oui mais pour autant j'assume de dire
qu'on peut évidemment élever des animaux
y compris à des fins d'élevage de
manière à pouvoir rêver l'exigence avec
le poisson par exemple c'est vrai que je
l'ait peut-être - enfin je regarde ça
vient pas ce qui est l'élevage
je regarde que d'élevage notamment sur
son nom qui est assez caractéristique de
ce point de vue là j'en consomme
objectivement moins que de la viande est
donc je fais plus attention quand je
consomme de la viande mais y compris je
pense qu'on est au restaurant de fait de
demander d'où proviennent les aliments
je pense que ça c'est quelque chose qui
est important aussi c'est d'autant plus
que nous notamment dans ce territoire en
ile de france on a la chance de pouvoir
s'alimenter de manière assez local donc
veut dire que ce serait un buzz qui
provient ce n'est d'ile-de-france mais
même parfois de l'étranger
là il ya quelque chose qui n'est pas qui
n'est pas cohérent qui n'aurait pas de
sens et ça je pense que c'est notre
vigilance à nous de consommateurs qui
doit vraiment être beaucoup plus aiguisé
et qu'il est de plus en plus c'est pour
ça d'ailleurs que les restaurateurs ont
changé la donne que nos producteurs ont
changé la donne et qu'il ya beaucoup
plus de traçabilité que ce qu'on pouvait
alors on va continuer à en parler mais
on va voir si vous êtes vraiment
incollables tout de suite c'est le quiz
est alors chantre du bien-être animal
aurore bergé vous n'êtes pas fan bien
sûr des poules en batterie même si c'est
compliqué des interdits on verra ça
peut-être tout à l'heure dans la
discussion c'est le thème en tous les
cas de ce premier quiz
on va voir si vous êtes incollable en
matière de volaille laquelle de ces
appellations ne correspond pas une
espèce de poules vous pouvez le voir sur
l'écran donc à celle a connu du forez le
forez c'est la région autour de
saint-etienne baisser la sologne hot
c'est c'est le coucou de rennes et des
la gauloise doré donc parmi ces quatre
appellations il y en a une qui ne fait
pas référence à une volaille ou à une
poule pour parler plus prosaïquement une
poule à écouter non j'ai fait un bien
énorme et je réservais dernière quand
même la gauloise devrait avec un nom
pareil
donc c'est vraiment une foule de chez
nous lé doré et gauloises non la réponse
b c solognote parce qu'on change
complètement d'espèce c'est une espèce
de banio voilà alors cette fois la photo
voilà solognote magnifique animal que la
conque ou draine aussi exister jolie
vous sur place
on a un deuxième quiz pour vous alors
votre père alain berger est la voix
française de sylvester stallone ça nous
a évidemment beaucoup interpellé quand
on a lu ça il a notamment interprété
rambo pour jouer ces rôles d'acteurs
alors rambo il se musclait grâce à des
régimes qui était hyper protéiné c'est
donc le thème de ce quiz que vous allez
pouvoir découvrir lequel de ces morceaux
john est le plus protéine est alors à la
bavette de boeuf b le foie de veau c'est
le gigot d'agneau et des le filet rôti
maigre de port plus protéines celui que
manger le plus alors je suis pas sûr que
ce soit un des quatre pour être honnête
qu'il aurait mangés au jeu des gélules
plutôt que de la poudre poteau mais
c'est pas vrai je sais qu'il
s'entraînait en cognant contre 1 devait
aussi j'ai plongé sans trop long je
faisais des régimes hyperprotéinés
pourraient être communiqués de presse je
ne crois pas tout à fait naturel et
j'hésite entre les deux premiers
je veux dire le boeuf mais mais mais ni
l'un ni l'autre annonce sur ses causes
allô c'est le rôti de porc teza rôti de
porc qui porte mal son nom
oui avec près de 30 g de protéines pour
100 g c'était un tir de protéines alors
que les autres on est plutôt près de 19
grammes ou 22 g
c'était une question êtes vous en faites
oui mais moi aussi je me serais trompé
aussi gens tiennent bien ce jeu alors
vous vous êtes très engagé en politique
est pourtant donc on a appris que votre
père était la voix de sylvester stallone
votre maman la voie d'une actrice très
connue des feux de l'amour
on parlait modular et beauté attention à
montfort et porter haut la main de dieu
quelle erreur du coup on parlait c'était
quoi vous étiez baigné dans ce monde de
la culture où dans le monde politique où
les 2 2 mais je retire mes parents sont
comédiens donc j'ai la chance d'avoir
été les élever dans les livres élevé
dans la musique en allant depuis ma plus
tendre enfance au cinéma et au théâtre
donc ça je pense que c'est une chance
inestimable en termes de transmission et
ça j'en ai bien conscience
mais j'ai aussi été mais est élevé et
met d'ailleurs dans le débat c'est à
dire que pour le coup au travers des
repas familiaux qu'on pouvait avoir même
si on était trop à table puisque je suis
fils unique
on parlait et on parlait tout le temps
politique est donc de vos parents et
passionné de politique est quasi nulle
je pense comme beaucoup de français il
aime la vie politique n'aime pas
toujours les hommes et femmes politiques
mais il aime la vie politique et
génération sur son site un peu ou pas
les ratios complètement 68 mon père
était au conservatoire d'art dramatique
de paris
en 68 donc il a mené la fronde du
conservatoire à ce moment là contre les
barricades
il a tenu en fait le conservatoire
pendant pendant 68 y compris face à des
tentatives d'intrusion l'extrême droite
maman passer son bac cette année là ils
ont été très engagé papa encore plus
parce qu'il est étudiant à cette époque
là dans les différents mouvements les
manifestations ma grand mère se souvient
être allé le récupérer au commissariat
longtemps il a été il a été extrêmement
engagés dans cette période est donc je
pense qu'en tout cas cette fibre là qui
n'a jamais été un engagement partisan
les ont jamais adhéré à un parti
politique mais cette fibre d'engagement
moi et me l'ont clairement transmises
et puis la chance d'être entourée de
beaucoup d'adultes en fait j'ai tout le
temps des amis de mes parents qui sonne
à la maison et d'avoir toujours eu la
chance de pouvoir être avec eux à table
le monde de la culture qui est très
politisé il y avait aussi le monde de la
culture oui mais moi je n'ai jamais
ressenti comme ça mais j'avais le pas
pour l'utiliser au sens noble du terme
que des avis oui il y avait des avis tu
sais quoi j'ai une chance d'être avec
des gens qui étaient intelligents qui
transmettait qui apprenait des choses et
on n'a jamais considéré que parce que
j'étais une enfant j'avais pas droit de
m'exprimer
donc même si j'avais 6 ans et en ut en
gt2 n'est pas très élevé parce qu'ici
piège à la relève et chic et tout à
l'heure quand je vous présentais sur
l'ailé droite de la majorité
souvent on attribue les intellectuels au
monde de gauche finalement à la gauche
est ce que c'est une erreur et est ce
que ça vous est ce que ça vous choque
non mais j'ai tiqué sur la droite et sur
l gauche parce que moi je n'aime plus me
définir comme ça parce que sinon ça veut
dire qu'en marge ça fonctionne pas c'est
à dire on n'a pas créé la république en
marche chez moi j'ai adhéré
après la primaire de la droite moi je
fais toute la campagne d'alain juppé
alain juppé perd la primaire de la
droite et je fais le choix de ne pas
m'engager pour françois fillon parce que
justement je considérais que ça
correspondait pas aux valeurs et aux
convictions qui étaient les miennes et
que j'avais envie de porter dans cette
campagne et je rejoins neil macron aussi
sur cette promesse lacs et de dire
finalement est-ce qu'on peut pas réussir
à faire travailler ensemble ce que nous
ont demandé mille fois les français des
gens qui finalement était pas si
éloignées donc si moi-même
après trois ans en tant que député je
continue à dire je représente la droite
etc
je pense pas j'ai je représente les
chauffeurs des convictions qui sont les
miennes et qui n'ont pas changé mais je
crois que c'est heureusement peu plus
compliqué que ça aujourd'hui
juste une petite curiosité brita parce
que quand on a un papa qui prête sa voix
à un boxeur ce canton doit aller se
coucher
oui aux kiwis silver certaine quand on
doit aller se coucher on doit filer doux
donc quand on est enfant il m'a jamais
parlé de la même manière rassurez vous
c'est ce que je vais savoir son papa
sont environ vous l'avez jamais
rencontré ces lois sur ses talons
clermont rencontré plusieurs reprises
mais pas moi mais mon père l'a rencontré
à plusieurs reprises en france on sait
que le déjeuner occupe une assez large
place et notamment aux politiques
alors on vous a demandé de réfléchir à
un souvenir politique c'est la brève de
comptoir
alors effectivement il se passe quand
même beaucoup de choses en politique et
notamment à table avec des hommes ou des
femmes politiques est ce que vous vous
avez une longue carrière politique
malgré votre jeune âge
est-ce que vous avez un souvenir qui
vous est revenue partirai quand vous
avez posé la question j'essaie de me
souvenir s'il y avait vraiment un repas
marquant ou pas et en fait j'ai pas
vraiment trouvé deux repas avec un homme
avec une femme politique qui voit là
aurait marqué mon esprit mais sur la
question du repas et la place du repas
en positif mois il se trouve que les
circonscriptions qui est la mienne est
aussi celle de gérard larcher a remarqué
qu'un certain nombre de différences
entre entre lui et moi et il a une
réputation en effet de gastronomes on va
dire ça comme ça
et donc c'est vrai que quand on se
retrouve très régulièrement ensemble
dans des manifestations dans des
événements notamment dans les cérémonies
de voeux
disons que on n'a pas tout à fait la
même pratique après dubuffet ou de la
table et c'est donc y avait 80 c'est
plutôt le batteur oui non mais je lui
dis de manière positive parce que je
pense que en france être un bon vivant
c'est plutôt quelque chose de positif et
j'ai pas l'impression non plus de trop
me restreindre mais c'est vrai que c'est
un peu différent et c'est vrai que nous
aussi à l'assemblée je sais qu'on a un
peu bousculé les helvètes de l'assemblée
où on ne mangeait kavcic du quinoa et
didier du coq à l'âne j'ai jamais mangé
de le quesnoy
mais le coca light sweed
ça oui et c'est vrai que on consomme
beaucoup moins d'alcool à la buvette de
l'assemblée c'est pareil je dis en
circonscription parce qu'ils étaient
habitués à servir d'autres choses ou
quand des mers m'invite pour faire des
déjeuners c'est vrai que voilà après on
correspond à des générations aussi
qu'ils sont différents donc je pense que
le rapport à la table des juges il est
extrêmement important
ça oui mais comme on est aussi très
nombreux députés notamment dans celles
et ceux qui sont arrivés il ya trois ans
on avait des vies professionnelles
auparavant on a eu aussi des rapports un
petit peu différent de ceux qui ont été
élus depuis 30 ans qui avait ses
habitudes à l'étude au grand banquet
républicain lankais et puis de deux
repas qui s'étire et cetera
nous on a un petit peu un petit peu
changé la donne je fais c'est bien en
tout cas je sais que voilà il ya eu
baisse de la consommation d'alcool à
l'assemblée allez on va parler un peu
politique maintenant et on va passer à
la deuxième partie de cette émission on
met les pieds dans le plat dans les
pieds dans le plat vous nous direz si
emmanuel macron a trop attendu avant de
lutter contre le séparatisme
faut-il ajouter un volet sur l'éducation
sinon comment mieux protéger des
professeurs ou comment mieux enseigner
la laïcité
les réseaux sociaux se font l'écho de
propos terroristes comment sanctionner
les auteurs que peut-on attendre des
plateformes et le diocèse nous avait
rejoints sur ce plateau vous êtes
journaliste politique on peut voir
notamment sur ses news et puis gym gère
assez bonjour vous êtes rédacteur en
chef adjoint au figaro bonjour aux
bergers l'attentât qui a visé
samuel patier eu lieu à
conflans-sainte-honorine dans les
yvelines c'est aussi le département vous
même être élu quand on est député quand
on représente précisément ce territoire
comment on vit ce drame ça c'est un
département qui a été soumis à rude
épreuve on avait aussi vécu l'assassinât
des deux policiers aux mureaux qui
avaient été assassinés dans leur
domicile et devant leurs enfants
donc malheureusement c'est un
département qui a déjà suivi des drame
innommable
là je crois que celui ci il ya eu un
effet de sidération qui a été encore
plus puissants parce que c'était en
plein jour en pleine rue un enseignant
qui enseignait tout simplement en fait
et qui a été une
bon assez signer pour le fait d'avoir
d'avoir enseigné donc ça a suscité une
vague d'émotion évidemment à travers
l'ensemble du pays mais je pense
d'autant plus forte dans le département
où très vite on a eu besoin de se
retrouver donc et beaucoup de dommages
citoyens dès le lendemain dès le samedi
moi j étais dans un village une toute
petite commune de ma circonscription
parce que les gens aient besoin de
parler qu'est-ce qui vous disais
justement les administrés déjà il y
avait le fait d'avoir besoin d'être
ensemble et de partager cette sidération
parce que finalement on avait du mal à
réaliser ce qui s'était passé
c'est ça qui à mon avis on a encore du
mal aujourd'hui semaines après à
réaliser que ça ait pu se produire et
que ça allait plus produire à l'encontre
d'un enseignant uniquement pour le
simple fait qu'il est enseigné que des
collégiens les désigner et donc
finalement les envoyer à mort alors
espérer qu'il n'en avait pas conscience
ou moins ils l'ont fait mais enfin il ya
tout cet enchaînement de fêtes en plus
ce qui ajoute à l'horreur du crime qui a
été commis et qui rajoute encore une
fois aussi se faisait au sentiment
d'impuissance et à dire comment en tant
que citoyen on peut concrètement aussi
agir qu'est ce qu'on aurait pu ou dû
faire et une inquiétude très forte
évidemment de la communauté enseignante
les enseignants est en vacances à partir
de vendredi soir et ils s'inquiètent et
je comprends évidemment pour la rentrée
scolaire comme en cette rentrée va se
passer comment expliquer aux enfants à
nouveau leur métier quel est ce que ça
va changer un rapport entre les
enseignants et les parents d'élèves qui
vont peut-être enfin se sentir plus
solidaire des enseignant-es qui sont
passées vous avez évoqué la commune ddd
muros et c'est la commune qui a choisi
emmanuel macron pour présenter son texte
en sur le séparatisme il le présente
plus de trois ans après son arrivée à
l'elysée alors que la menace terroriste
finalement est connue de longue date au
moins depuis 2015 et les premiers
attentats de charlie est ce qu'il n'a
pas trop tardé quand même manuel macron
à prendre conscience de l'ampleur de ce
que nos veines 3 que l'abe la prise de
conscience elle est dès le premier jour
déjà parce que pendant la campagne
présidentielle elle même juste avant le
premier tour on a un attentat qui se
produisent sur les champs-elysées et
donc je pense que personne aucun
candidat à l'élection présidentielle
en ciel aucun président de la république
peut ne pas avoir conscience de
l'ampleur de la menace qui pèse sur
chacune et sur chacun d'entre nous après
la question c'est comment est-ce qu'on
doit adresser cette menace est ce que
c'est de nouveaux textes législatifs qui
sont nécessaires on a eu à la fois au
tout début du mandat
la sortie de l'état d'urgence qui avait
été annoncé pendant la campagne
présidentielle et un certain nombre de
ces mesures qui sont entrés est aussi
l'endroit comme vous souvenez aussi du
débat que ça avait suscité à l'époque on
nous disait qu'on allait trop loin
horace daniel ek berton restreignent les
libertés publiques qu'on ne devait pas
intégrer ces mesures dans le droit
commun en fait évidemment que si
malheureusement on aurait tous préféré
que ces mesures n'est pas à être intégré
dans le droit commun mais ça devient
nécessaire parce qu'encore une fois la
menace elle est permanente et puis après
il ya la question du discours politique
est ce qu'on a besoin à un moment
d'avoir ce un niveau d'expression et en
attend en vérité que ce soit
systématiquement le président de la
république qu'il fasse c'est à dire que
sur ces sujets sur ces questions là qui
sont des questions à la fois sur
l'identité de notre pays sur la capacité
à résister à la menace qui peut être
autant intérieur qu'extérieur
est ce que on attend la parole du
ministre de la justice ou du ministre de
l'intérieur où des parlementaires en
vérité c'est la parole présidentielle
qu'on attend et je pense que c'était
nécessaire que lui même puisse
s'exprimer sur cette question mme
roberge et sur ces trois ans je rebondis
sur la question de gym on voit que le
gouvernement fait feu de tout bois
aujourd'hui on a l'impression qu'ils
veulent rattraper quand même ce temps
perdu ses trois ans de perdus ça donne
cette impression
gérald darmanin qui est partout partout
effectivement est ce qu on se hait ce
que vous êtes quand même pas conscience
peut-être que ces trois ans n'ont pas
été mis à profit pour faire toutes les
mesures qu'on est en train de prendre
aujourd'hui pas dans la précipitation
mais c'est assez spectaculaire des
choses il ya qu'est ce qu'on a pu faire
en trois ans et il ya le moment
particulier convient en trois ans on a
augmenté les capacités de nos forces de
l'ordre on a continué les recrutements
on a enfin rémi decker les
renseignements territoriaux qui avait
été complètement zappé et on voit bien à
quel point on a besoin d'avoir des
renseignements dans nos territoires et
pas uniquement organisée au niveau
national on a fermé des lieux de
radicalisation on a pris des
dispositions pour lutter contre les
écoles qui sont hors contrat et c'est
donc on a un certain nombre non
seulement
dispositifs nouveaux qui ont été mis en
place de moyens qui ont été renforcées
et d'un caractère opérationnel aussi une
fois 356 lieu de radicalisation qui ont
été fermées en trois ans c'est tout sauf
à nantes anodin est évidemment un
certain nombre d'attentats déjoués après
il ya deux choses 1
on communique rarement sur les succès on
le sait c'est pas la culture du
ministère de l'intérieur
et on comprend aussi pourquoi on ne doit
pas communiquer sur ses succès pour
justement ne pas créer un climat qui
soit un climat trop anxiogène
après ce que je remarque aussi c'est que
peut-être que pour la première fois je
sais pas si c'est durable ou pas et
c'est peut-être ça aussi qui permet
cette accélération
aujourd'hui dans les mesures qui sont
annoncées et mises en oeuvre par le
ministre de l'intérieur c'est qu'enfin
tout le monde donne le sentiment d'avoir
pris conscience du problème et ce
n'était pas le cas il ya trois ans on
voit beaucoup a été fait mais il ya
quand même un trou dans la raquette et
notamment là on le voit c'est sur les
réseaux sociaux vous avez essayé avec la
loi via de contrôler ou de donner les
moyens aux plateformes en tout cas
qu'elles contrôlent davantage
aujourd'hui est-ce qu'il faut changer la
constitution pour pouvoir intervenir sur
les réseaux sociaux freiner ces messages
de haine voire ses appels au meurtre
je comprend enfin je comprends cette
question mais déjà plusieurs choses en
ce que j'entends sur l'anonymat sur les
réseaux sociaux c'est pas du tout le
problème qui s'est posé la personne ne
s'est exprimée une manière anonyme pour
autant vous n'êtes pas sauf ceux qui ont
répondu au tweet nom paul est retrouvée
s'est exprimée sous son nom celui de
vivre dans une association islamiste et
s'est exprimée sous sont donc on laisse
mal anonyme ap ap un sendra qu'il y en
aurait la question de la levée de
l'anonymat vous avez aussi sur des
réseaux sociaux aujourd'hui des
enseignants qui s'exprime de manière
anonyme pour réussir à contester leur
métier les avocats des magistrats etc
vous avez aussi faut aussi considérer
que dans un certain nombre d'autres pays
qui sont moins démocratique que le nôtre
si vous n'avez pas la garantie de
l'anonymat
vous avez des militants politiques ne
pourront plus s'exprimer oui l'anonymat
est levé la nominative ans il est dans
ce qui s'est passé dans cet attentat
c'est pas la question de l'anonymat qui
est qui en question et preuve en est
encore une fois ils se sont exprimés à
visage découvert ce qui est peut-être
encore plus inquiétant d'ailleurs sur ce
que s'est dit après sur la question des
réseaux sociaux ils sont un vecteur
avant tout
et ils sont le syndrome d'une société
qui est malade et qui est malade parce
que en effet dans les vingt dernières
années et c'est ce que je disais cette
semaine à l'assemblée c'est à dire que
on a eu vingt années d'une naïveté de
l'acheter sur ces sujets là donc est-ce
qu'il faut renforcer les règles sur la
question des réseaux sociaux
peut-être est-ce qu'il faut surtout
renforcer l'efficacité opérationnelle
c'est-à-dire que quand on voit qu'il y a
harcèlement ciblées qui est en train de
se mettre en place à l'encontre d'un
enseignant ou un an contre c'est pas
d'un pompier d'un journaliste d'un
fonctionnaire fin de quelqu'un qui est
dépositaire d'une forme d'autorité ou de
pouvoir public
alors comment le signalement doit être
fait et comment les contenus doivent
être retirés
est ce que pour autant on considère
qu'il faut donner le pouvoir aux
plateformes de décider par elles mêmes
quels sont les contenus qui mériterait
d'être retiré je sais pas certaine qu'on
ait envie d'en arriver là et que ce soit
une bonne chose qu'on en arrive là parce
qu'encore une fois que c'est à la
puissance publique de prendre ce que les
la puissance publique de pouvoir le
contrat vraiment le sens de la loi
carrez je pense que c'est à la puissance
utile de renforcer les moyens pharos
notamment qui est la plateforme de
signalement se côtoient les moyens
financiers et donc humain être largement
largement conforté vous voyez aussi
aujourd'hui par exemple que le risque
que vous avez quand vous demandez aux
plateformes de contrôler et donc de
retirer des contenus
c'est qu'elle se finalement elle ouvre
le parapluie et donc que vous ayez un
certain nombre de contenus qu'on ne veut
pas voir être retirés qu'ils le soient
demain et d'ailleurs vous avez beaucoup
de militants qui sont des militants
laïques républicain et qui ont vu leurs
contenus sur twitter être retirés
pourquoi parce que tout d'un coup vous
avez des milliers de signalements à
l'encontre de compte qui sont des
comptes complètement démocratique et
républicain et donc forcément la
plateforme ne voulant pas prendre de
risques préfèrent retirer ce contenu les
femen ont vu leurs contenus être retirée
on peut contester leurs modalités
d'action enfin objectivement on voit
bien qu'on peut pas les comparer à des
modalités d'action des islamistes dans
la manière avec laquelle il se propage
sur les réseaux sociaux
donc moi je suis fait ensuite très
vigilante sur la question
plus globalement depuis vendredi les
partis politiques font assaut de
propositions sur la question de l'islam
l'islamisme radical
la droite réclame elle devait son cas
c'est classique et un durcissement des
mesures un renforcement de l'arsenal
pour faire la guerre fasse face à ce
fléau la gauche elle insiste plus sur
lesquels la question qui laisse des
inégalités de la ghettoïsation
est ce que en marche peut incarner une
sorte d' en même temps entre ces deux
voies ces deux solutions pour lutter
contre le fléau de l'islamisme radical
ou escapade en même temps possible sur
cette question sur la question de la
lutte contre le séparatisme islamistes
ya pas deux en même temps possible ça je
le dis de manière très claire
quand on veut lutter contre le
séparatisme islamistes et qu'on dit
qu'on est un pays qui est en guerre
parce que justement on nous a déclaré
cette guerre là alors on doit lutter de
manière extraordinairement efficace
ça veut dire lutter contre la
radicalisation ça veut dire lutter
contre la déscolarisation
ça veut dire renforcer les moyens
opérationnels de nos forces de l'ordre
ça veut dire expulser les étrangers qui
sont radicalisées comme ça a été annoncé
par le ministre de l'intérieur
c'est-à-dire fermé des lieux de
radicalisation ça veut dire la question
du contrôle des prêches aussi qu'ils
peuvent être faits c'est la question de
la radicalisation présent c'est à dire
c'est l'ensemble de ces chants qui
doivent être largement confortée et
renforcée après se dire que le
terrorisme se nourrit du séparatisme
cela mist et finalement à un terreau qui
est plus favorable
évidemment malheureusement sur des
quartiers qui sont des quartiers plus en
tension qui sont des quartiers plus
prioritaires qui sont du quartier vous
avez une forme de séparatisme social
oui mais je pense qu'il faut surtout pas
qu'on mélange ces deux sujets parce que
déjà un rire rien ne justifie qu'on
puisse accréditer cette thèse qu'on
puisse les propager son relaunch vous
aimez mais moi je vois bien le
relativisme qui existe dans un certain
nombre de partis à gauche c'est à dire
que quand on a un attentat comme celui
qu'on a vécu la semaine dernière et que
la première réponse n'est pas une
réponse d'une extrême fermeté
républicaine mais que tout de suite
c'est une réponse qui cherche à
comprendre si ce n'est à excuser en tout
cas à amoindrir ce qui s'est passé en
disant finalement le vrai problème il
n'est pas dans la lutte contre le
séparatisme islamistes mais il est
d'abord dans la lutte contre tel ou tel
jeu c'est pas faux mais noté communauté
à propos des tchétchènes
enfin jean luc mélenchon se réveille sur
le sujet tant mieux un grand bien lui
fasse
moi je suis pas là
manifestation dimanche parce que j'avais
pas envie de marcher à côté de la france
un sourire parce que j'avais marché
rêver main c'est dans la marche pour le
moment on ne peut pas sur ces sujets là
tergiversé en permanence on veut pas
être hypocrite sur ces questions là moi
je ne marche pas à côté de ceux du
comité adama traoré en fait à un moment
si on veut lutter avec efficacité
il faut enfin qu'on dise clairement quel
est le mal dans ce pays et qu'on
l'adresse et quand on vous dit
finalement il ya une accélération
aujourd'hui je pense que cette
accélération elle est possible
aujourd'hui parce que vous avez enfin un
climat politique qui change dans le pays
et qui n'est pas un climat politique qui
viendrait donner raison à l'extrême
droite parce que c'est tout de suite de
cela quand que l'on est accusée
immédiatement c'est juste un climat
politique qui dit qu'enfin on considère
et qui a pour l'instant en tout cas une
forme de concorde qui existe là dessus
pour se dire que le mal qu'on doit
traiter
il ronge notre société et qu'on ne peut
plus accepter que ça continue qu'on
concorde y compris au sein de votre
majorité on a vu que que le gouvernement
souhaite remanier l'observatoire de la
laïcité qui est dirigé par des anciens
socialistes en l'occurrence jean louis
bianco qui sont accusés d'être ambiguë
ou lac si je sais pas quel est le terme
il ya un certain nombre de députés de
votre groupe qui ont pris la défense
justement de jean louis bianco et de
nicolas cadène qui dirige cet
observatoire est ce que du coup il ya
deux lignes au sein de la majorité
c'est un sujet qui est quand même un peu
différent de celui de la lutte contre le
terrorisme
quand même après mon action c'est pas
est-ce qu'ils sont anciens socialistes
ump l air ce pas le sujet la question
c'est quelles sont les missions qu'on
assigne à l'observatoire de la laïcité
si on considère que l'observatoire est
utile parce qu'il permet justement
d'observer les phénomènes que l'on a
dans notre société de mesurer les
attentes qui sont faites à la laïcité
comme par exemple jean michel blanquer
le fai manière très claire au sein de
l'école alors il faut qu'on ait des gens
qui souhaitent inflexible sur ces
questions là or je considère
qu'aujourd'hui l'observateur de la
laïcité a passé plus de temps à lutter
contre des laïcs dans notre pays qu'il a
passé du temps
finalement à essayer de renforcer les
principes qui sont les nôtres ils ont eu
des attitudes qui sont ambigus ils ont
accepté de préfacer des livres par
exemple quand on accepte de préfacé le
livre de l'avocat du ccf
je suis désolé mais je crois que ça
interpelle quand même on n'est pas sur
une association on est sur un organisme
qui est un organisme public d'état
financé par les français
donc moi je pense que l'outil est utile
mais qu'aujourd'hui son pilotage et
inefficace voire même contre-productive
vous êtes le seul qui disent il faut
faire le ménage dans ce jeu je crois que
dans la période
il faut accepter de faire le ménage
partout où c'est nécessaire pour
qu'enfin on ait des principes
républicains et laïcs qu'ils soient très
clairement énoncé qui soit très
clairement ensuite mis en oeuvre tout
simplement
donc la question c'est pas pour ou
contre telle ou telle personne à 2009
c'est juste si l'outil est bon alors il
faut encore une fois que ils en aient
les moyens et que le seul et ce qu'il
incarne soit conforme à la ligne qui est
celle du gouvernement
et vous parlez de nommer le mal vous
notamment vous aviez pointé du doigt
justement la responsabilité du collectif
contre l'islamophobie en france disant
qu'ils avaient participé à cette chasse
à l'homme maintenant j'ai un darmanin
veut le dissoudre mais est-ce que c'est
pas un petit peu tard ce mal vous
connaissiez finalement avant et c'est
justement maintenant que les mesures
sont prises il a fallu en arriver là
pour qu'enfin on prenne des mesures
alors moi j'ai pas l'impression d'avoir
tardé à nommer les choses peuvent
trouver des déclarations de ma part sur
ces sujets là qui sont tout à fait
constante dont j'ai jamais eu de
difficulté à nommer le mal sur sur
l'islamisme en particulier sur le ccf ça
fait de nombreuses années qu'on ait un
certain nombre à dénoncer cette
organisation est que oui on a eu parfois
l'impression de ne pas être suffisamment
soutenue dans la manière avec laquelle
on pouvait dénoncer les choses parce que
c'est difficile aussi de les combattre
parce que à partir du moment où vous les
combattez vous êtes attaqué en
diffamation parce que ils mènent une
guérilla qui est une guérilla judiciaire
à l'encontre de celles et ceux qui osent
leur apporter la contradiction parce que
vous retrouvez avec un certain nombre de
menaces qui sont proférées là notamment
sur les réseaux sociaux ou souhaitait la
dissolution moi je souhaite pour aller à
son terme ministre a clairement dit
qu'il souhaitait que ça puisse être
dissous c'est quand même pas un hasard
si dans ce qui s'est produit
systématiquement les parents d'élèves
qui se sont insurgés et
ont commencé à mener ce lynchage et
cette chasse à l'homme se sont
revendiqués à chaque fois du ccf ont
donné les coordonnées du ccf donc à
aucun moment évidemment le ccf n'a dit
stop sur la manière avec laquelle ce
professeur était mis en cause au
contraire à chaque fois puis ça crée un
climat dans ce pays qui fait qu' ils
essayent de créer un véritable ces
périodes c'est à dire qu'ils les
essayent eux de dire aux musulmans dans
notre pays
en fait les lois aujourd'hui dans notre
pays sont faites contre vous quand il
fut organisé une marche contre
l'islamophobie ils disent quoi ils
disent il y à du racisme d'état
il y à un racisme anti musulman vers de
liens mais est-ce que la lutte contre
l'islam radical
elle passe par ne pas porter le voile
pour une femme lorsqu'elle accompagne
lors des sorties scolaires ou par
l'arrêt des menus confessionnels le fait
de ne pas manger de porc peut-être à la
cantine c'est des débats qu'on a qu'on a
déjà eu
vous connaissez mes positions sur la
question des cantines scolaires moi
jamais forcer un enfant qui mangent pas
peur à manger du porc enfin c est ce qu
il faut un lieu particulier ou est-ce
que ce jour là ils mangent des légumes
enfin honnêtement je pense que rouvrir
ce débat là ce serait extraordinairement
contre-productif maintenant surtout dans
ce moment là c'est à dire que amalgamer
ce qui se passe dans une cantine
scolaire
là où en général ça se passe bien c'est
à dire annoncé des maires qui ont fait
les choix en général d'ailleurs la
plupart du temps il ya des menus
végétariens qui ont été mis en place ce
qui permet justement de créer plus de
concorde et ne pas diviser entre ceux
qui prendraient tel ou tel type de repas
moi j'ai pas pour des repas
confessionnels l école publique et je
suis bloqué des alternatives parce qu'en
effet l'enfant soit capable de manger de
viande ont géré par quelque chose qu'il
fait c'est ce qui a été fait je suis ce
sujet qu'est ce que vous pensez de la
prise de position que gérald darmanin
/ kg à compter du doigt certains
certaines grandes surfaces qui mettent
des rayons communautaire de nourriture
communautaire en disant qu'il y avait
une
voilà qui faisait une économie là dessus
est-ce que c'était utile
écoutez je crois que les propos on était
quand même il ya eu 30 secondes qui ont
été extraites d'un propos qui étaient
beaucoup plus longs de la part de la
part du ministre je crois que ce qu'il
veut dire surtout c'est qu'à un moment
on peut pas avoir une forme de
séparatisme qui existent un peu partout
c'est à dire on peut pas avoir une
société qui serait comme ça fracturé
morcelé communauté contre communauté
c'est ça qui est important après des
personnes dans notre pays ait envie de
pouvoir vivre leur religion chez eux
la vivre dans leur famille et donc
pouvoir tout simplement trouver aussi la
capacité à s'alimenter fort le faire je
crois que c'est juste pas le débat et
c'est d'ailleurs parce qu'il a voulu
dire non plus donc encore une fois on a
un sujet qui est trop important pour
qu'on se divise sur des points qui
seraient plus accessoire et qui derrière
on le sait bien par la force du symbole
vous emporter tout le reste
parce qu'on ne parlera plus derrière des
vrais sujets quand on parle par contre
de la lutte contre la déscolarisation
ça c'est une question qui est essentiel
c'est dans le projet de la salle dans le
projet de loi mais de la même manière
quand jean michel blanquer moi je me
souviens très bien parce que je vois
bien le procès qu'on est en train
d'essayer de lui lui a tenté sur ce qui
s'est passé sur la manière avec laquelle
est ce que la hiérarchie est
suffisamment soutenu et c'est pour avoir
pour être dans ce département pour
connaître la rectrice pour connaître les
équipes qui travaillent au sein de
l'éducation nationale et notamment dans
les urines je peux vous dire que
clairement là toute la hiérarchie
d'éducation nationale a soutenu s'est
rendu sur place a accompagné
l'enseignant c'est ce qui est assez peu
commun dans par rapport à ce qu'on a
vécu dans le passé d'avoir une
directrice d'établissement qui va avec
l'enseignant porter plainte face aux
menaces qu'il subit de la part de
parents d'élèves de cette de ce même
établissement
mais jean michel blanc car il faut se
souvenir aussi des polémiques qui
existaient quant lui disait clairement
les choses dès le début du mandat sur ce
qui se passait je me souviens quand il
expliquait que notamment dans un certain
nombre d'écoles on avait des petits
garçons qui n'acceptait plus de se
mettre à côté des petites filles
tournon et mais il est complètement fou
il fantasmes nos messes jachère le seuil
de 20 depuis 2004 d'ailleurs c'est
françois fillon qui inquiète bien voulu
sauter qui a publié en tout cas ce
rapport vous êtes membre de la
commission des affaires culturelles
comment on arrive à ramener ses enfants
qui ne veulent pas justement chanter la
marseillaise qui se met en marche
parfois sur des questions de laïcité sur
la shoah sur beaucoup de questions
d'histoire
comment les ramènent et comment on
protège les professeurs face à ça mais
déjà il ya plusieurs sujets sains la
question évidemment de toutes les
associations de soutien scolaire et de
toute la partie déscolarisation déjà la
première des choses c'est de les ramener
à l'école et qu'elles soient privées
sous contrat ou qu'elles soient
publiques mais c'est de les ramener dans
un cadre qui est un champ républicain
aujourd'hui on a des enfants qui sont
substitués à la république et qu'on ne
voit pas qui sont complètement hors des
radars etc des milliers d'enfants et qui
là sont concentrées surtout dans un
certain nombre de nos quartiers et qui
du coup disparaissent complètement pour
nous c'est à dire on n'a plus aucun
droit de regard finalement sur ce qui se
passe est finalement très peu sur ce qui
se passe dans leur famille la première
chose c'est lutter de manière très
claire contre la déscolarisation prendre
la décision de dire qu'il faut qu'ils
aient une scolarisation obligatoire à
l'école des trois ans c'est une décision
qui est essentiel qui concerne
clairement un certain nombre
d'engagements et pour les clubs mais ça
commence par là parce qu'aussi de à
partir de vos trois ans vous échapper
complètement à l'école et au système
scolaire tel qu'il existe dans notre
pays vous imaginez bien derrière les
difficultés
ensuite ça veut dire que pour le coup il
faut pas qu'ils aient dû pas de vagues
ou de mettre la poussière sous le tapis
il faut que systématiquement dès qu'on a
des attentes claires à des principes
républicains c'est à dire dès qu'on a
des certificats de complaisance soit
disant pour des intolérances au chlore
pour que les petites filles n'aille pas
à la piscine dès qu'on a des minutes de
silence qui ne serait ce pas respectés
comme l'hommage que nous aurons à samuel
pâti comme ça avait pu exister déjà à
l'époque de charlie hebdo
alors il faut que ce soit
systématiquement signalés alors il faut
que les familles soient convoqués parce
qu'un enfant de six ans de 7 ans de 8
ans n'a pas l'idée seule de refuser de
respecter son silence et on va s'arrêter
là parce que le temps presse merci
elodie
avec nous on va bientôt passer au
dessert il nous sera servi et dans
quelques instants pour l'instant c'est
la troisième partie et c'est le dessous
des plats alors même au sein de ceux qui
se battent pour le bien-être animal rare
berger la question fait débat faut-il
interdire l'élevage intensif veaux
cochons poules entassées dans des
conditions épouvantables au nom de la
rentabilité
alors il existe bien des solutions
alternatives exemple dans le morvan avec
cet éleveur de vaches qui ont grèce
aussi une cinquantaine de ports en plein
air c'est un reportage de clément
perreault
[Musique]
fabrice voile aux élèves une
cinquantaine de ports dans cette
parcelle de maïs
le tout dans le parc régional du morvan
le grand luxe pour une vie de cochon
avec la canicule de fin septembre
ça leur sert des ombrages et aujourd'hui
ça leur serve d'aires de jeux à dans la
boue je ne je n'ai pas la psychologie du
cochon mais je pense qu'ils sont heureux
oui évidemment on le voit très bien ils
sont pas sauvages ils sont pas apeuré
ces ports sont ici pour l'heure face
d'engraissement qui dure cinq mois ils
sont d'une race standard la même que
dans les élevages intensifs et d'après
l'éleveur ils sont parfaitement adaptés
au plein air on a eu les fortes
canicules
on a eu la neige on a eu les jeunes et
on a eu le froid des moins 10 - 12 sans
aucun souci majeur
mais fabrice voile aux élèves surtout
des vaches charolaises les cochons pour
lui c'est juste une activité de
complément cela lui rapporte autour de
2500 euros par an avec huit autres
éleveurs il est intégré à une filière
haut de gamme baptisée thorpe les nerfs
morvan c'est un fabricant d'aliment
qu'il organise avec 1000 porcs par an la
production restent confidentielles et
n'a pas vocation à s'élargir
démesurément c'est un marché de niche
on pourrait pas faire que du pur plein
air pour nourrir toute la france c'est
possible pourquoi aujourd'hui c'est des
sites qui sont assez assez long nous on
fait du port de cinq mois six mois
contre du port ont affaire standard à
trois mois et demi les animaux ils ont
120 m² par cochon en bâtiment on est
plutôt à 0 65 m² par cochon donc si on
mettait tous les cochons bâtiment dehors
mais nous ferons une surface énorme quoi
prenez l'exemple des poules pondeuses
imaginons qu'on dise on a plus de poules
pondeuses en cages
en gros il faudrait libre libéré entre
hymne 200 millions de poules faudrait
mettre 200 millions de poules en plein
air alors imaginez déjà quand on voit le
fameux coq maurice sur sur son île
d'oléron le tollé pour un coq qui chante
imaginez 200 millions de poules en
pleine et une surface considérable
couplée à des coûts d'engraissement bien
plus élevé le port plein air n'est pas
prêt à remplacer du jour au lendemain
l'élevage industriel
d'autant que son prix est plus élevé
vérification sur l'étal du boucher les
côtes de porc le filet mignon de veau
les côtés chine
tout ça ça vient du porc élevé en plein
air du morvan d'une côte de porc ses 11
95 du port normal vous allez trouver à
8,9 euros qu'ils rencontrent surface là
non pas mon passé 6 euros 6,7 oh c'est
bon c'est plus cher que du porc il va en
batterie plus cher oui mais d'une
qualité nettement supérieure
c'est un petit peu plus plus ferme
l epa grâce du tout l epa granuleuse
mais c'est surtout après cuisson qu'on
voit la différence elle rétrécit pas
dans la poêle rend pas d'eau aujourd'hui
cette viande s'adresse d'abord à une
clientèle d'amateurs exigeants ou de
consommateurs soucieux du bien être
animal
aurore bergé vous avez vu ce reportage
il ya eu une proposition loi ici à
l'assemblée du groupe edf pour interdire
notamment l'élevage intensif et
l'élevage industriel est ce que vous
pensez que c'est utopique de vouloir
interdire cet élevage à industrielle et
intensive comme ça ou que c'est possible
parce que là on le voit sur une
cinquantaine de ports mais est-ce qu'on
pourrait vivre comme ça si on prend
l'exemple notamment du port si déjà on
devait demain transformer tous nos
élevages porcins en plein air ça
coûterait 13 milliards d'euros il y
aurait un investissement de 13 milliards
d'euros à réaliser pour permettre ce
changement et ensuite vous avez une
question de marché
c'est ce qui est démontré d'ailleurs
dans le reportage c'est à dire que
forcément ça coûte plus cher et ça coûte
vraiment plus cher et donc vous avez une
difficulté à la fois avec des français
qu'ils soient ne veulent pas soit ne
peuvent pas mettre ce prix
supplémentaires pour acheter une tranche
de jambon notamment donc on a aussi
cette question de marché et ensuite
moi je suis très soucieuse en effet des
modalités d'élevage des modalités
d'abattage aussi parce que souvent ce
que nous disent les éleveurs c'est que
notamment des éleveurs qui vraiment on
déployait des efforts importants qui se
sont modernisés c'est à une fois que les
animaux parts
il ya une question sur le transport est
une question sur l'abattage et sur cette
traçabilité donc ça il ya aussi cette
question là qui est essentielle
mais quand j'entendais notamment cédric
villani en parler lors de la proposition
de loi
on a l'impression qu'ils se réfèrent un
temps qui n'a pas existé c'est à dire on
fantasme ce qui se passait dans les
fermes ya 30 40 ou 50 ans mais enfin il
ya 30 40 ans va pas y avoir un mouvement
quand on amène pour aller vers ce que je
dis l'image tout cas c'était pas plus
respectueux du bien être animal ya 30 ou
40 ans au contraire
au contraire il n'y avait pas du tout
cette question que du respect du bien
être animal elle n'était pas encore
présente et d'ailleurs le métier était
encore plus difficile est donc
aujourd'hui les élevages se sont
largement améliorées alors justement
aujourd'hui du bien-être animal dans des
élevages nom très importants comme ça où
on a déjà un parce que la taille de
l'élevage ne veut rien dire sur la
question de bien-être animal vous pouvez
avoir un élevage très restreint ou pour
autant parce que vous pouvez avoir
uniquement une famille qui s'en occupent
mais qui peut avoir un moment des
difficultés moi je l' ai vécu dans mon
département c'est à dire que vous aviez
un moment un éleveur qui a pas pu
continuer à s'occuper de ces animaux
tout simplement parce qu'ils étaient
pris à la gorge parce que financièrement
il s'en sortait bien moi je vous parle
dit la veille et se cache comme il avait
vanté s'ils avaient sauté de veau donc
se dire parce que l'élevage est
restreint du coup il y aura une
attention supplémentaire au bien-être
animal non je peux vous donner d'autres
exemples chez moi pareil vous avez un
élevage de 500 vaches alors par des gens
pourraient olemps 500 vaches c'est pas
possible
ben moi je les invite à venir et à voir
comment on peut respecter le bien-être
animal parce qu'on fait preuve
d'innovation
parce qu'on a des employés qui y
travaillent et parce que je peux vous
dire pour les avoir rencontrés qu'on n'a
pas un qui accepteraient qu'on touche à
hand ces animaux et sur les poules parce
que ça a été un des gros sujets mais la
filière elle a fait des efforts
considérables et encore et encore a fait
en 3 % je encore à faire au berger me
suis dit là il va falloir quand même
abaisser le cet élevage intensif
comment on va s'en sortir quel est le
quelles sont les solutions pour sortir
de ce système d'élevage intensif d un
jour sur la consommation de viande
désert sur les habitudes alimentaires
plusieurs choses hein parce que les fier
aujourd'hui s'ils sont déjà engagées
notamment sur la question de l'élevage
de poules puisque c'était un des
premiers sujets sur le les cas les
poules en cage
aujourd'hui alors que l'engagement
c'était 50 % d'élevage hors cash pour
on est déjà 53% d'élevage hors cage en
2020 donc ça ça veut dire que ça
fonctionne aussi parce que il ya une
traçabilité
une attente très forte des consommateurs
on voit aussi dans la manière avec
laquelle s'est mis en valeur en
rayonnages où clairement c'est devenu en
atouts pour aller chercher le
consommateur d'avoir ce type de produits
qui sont mis en vente non tel ou tel
supermarché ou directement évidemment à
la fin donc oui il faut aller beaucoup
plus loin encore des images diffusées
par l214 des vidéos épouvantable sa
guise de tournée hors du boulot ces
vidéos elles sont insupportables elles
sont épouvantables il doit y avoir
systématiquement dans ces cas là les
enquêtes sanitaires et des contrôles qui
doivent être faits est ce que pour
autant ces images elles suffisent à
résumer tout un secteur non et ce serait
profondément injuste de considérer
aujourd'hui que nos agriculteurs et que
nos éleveurs soient limités à une image
à une vidéo aussi désastreux souhaité l
et vous vous avez bien soigné le rip
sauf erreur de ma part ce référendum
d'initiative populaire notamment pour
interdire l'élevage intensif
vous êtes un goethe a fait signer
un accord moi je les signe pour
plusieurs raisons 1 parce que j'en avais
assez que ce sujet là soit considéré
comme un sujet qui était finalement
extraordinairement secondaire parce que
à chaque fois sur ces questions nous dit
finalement ça peut bien attendre et
c'est un mystère
sauf que c'est une demande extrêmement
forte des citoyens qui nous pousse à
agir et donc ya pas deux ans perd pas on
ne peut pas en permanence maudire
finalement vous verrez bien et je peux
vous dire que sur ce sujet depuis trois
ans pourrait travailler avec des députés
de mon groupe au départ en nous
regardent avec des yeux un peu et bailly
en disant bon en plus c'était que des
femmes avoir travaillé au départ sur ce
sujet pour elles sont bien sympas mais
c'est pas la priorité du moment
et puis elles vont tourner s'occuper de
leur chat et de leur chien et ce sera
bien suffisant
il y avait quand même beaucoup de
condescendance il ya encore peu de temps
quand on voulait s'occuper un peu
sérieusement de ces questions là qui
sont importantes quand même parce que
c'est la traçabilité tout simplement de
notre alimentation c'est la capacité
aussi à mieux rémunérer nos agriculteurs
et nos éleveurs parce qu'il vous vous
avez fait ça pour faire bouger les
choses moi je veux que ça ça bougeait a
pas mal de propositions qui n'ont pas pu
passer à l'assemblée nationale est ce
qu'elles vont revenir à ce qu'elles vont
être reprises par le groupe majoritaire
moi je souhaite clairement qu'on puisse
porter dans mon groupe une proposition
de loi sur la question du bien-être
animal de manière très large c'est à la
fois la question de l'achat compulsif
des animaux parce que en animalerie
objectivement ça n'est pas approprié et
c'est pas là cette manière là que vous
pouvez du qu'un enfant quand ils voient
en effet derrière des petites vitres un
bébé labrador où forcément il a qu'une
envie c'est de le récupérer de le
ramener chez lui je pense qu'on l'a tous
vécu
sauf que derrière l'achat compulsif ça
vous prépare pas ensuite être en
capacité d'éduquer et d'élever un animal
donc vous avez cette pression-là et
l'abandon on est quand même encore une
fois aujourd'hui
le recordman d'europe de l'abandon des
animaux
donc on à ce sujet-là de rapport à
l'animal et de maltraitance qui doit
absolument être amélioré on doit
améliorer aussi les conditions sur
l'élevage mais je crois très sincèrement
pour y avoir travaillé que aujourd'hui
les filières ont démontré qu'elle savait
améliorer les conditions d'élevage et le
faire de manière très claire si en
permanence on essaye de jeter du
discrédit et on trouvera malheureusement
toujours une image malheureux on
trouvera toujours une vidéo
insupportable ça veut pas dire qu'il
faut pas les condamner ça veut juste
dire qu'on peut pas résumer le
professeur c'est dommage d'ailleurs à
cause de ça quoi aujourd'hui moi ce qui
m'inquiète plus c'est le taux de suicide
de nos agriculteurs
c'est une des professeurs revenu et je
suis sûr d'être élu
les revenus de nos agriculteurs où on a
quasiment un éleveur sur trois qui
produit du lait qui nous dit qu'il va
arrêter qui va arrêter
et qu'est ce qu'on veut on veut à la fin
emportez du lait ne plus être souverain
sur ces questions a donc il ya aussi ça
et donc je pense qu'il faut être aussi
très vigilants dans la manière avec
laquelle on en parle alors il nous reste
quelques minutes on passe au péché
mignon à le moelleux au chocolat aurore
bergé un symbole d'une pâtisserie
galvaudé parce que quand on voit que
dans toutes ses brasseries parisiennes
où ses restaurants on peut manger ce
petit moelleux au chocolat mais qui a
été confectionné sous vide juste
réchauffer au dernier moment alors
qu'ils demandent beaucoup d'attention le
fait maison voilà le fait maison est ce
qui fait la réussite c'est bien sûr
cette petite croûte
mais surtout ce coeur coulant fond dans
le secret c'est bien sûr de mettre cette
pâtisserie au réfrigérateur et la faire
chauffer 6 à 7 minutes puisque le gâteau
n'aura pas le temps de cuire et que le
choeur sera encore fonde en écoulant
alors que le four chauffé l'extérieur la
voilà alors on va essayer on va faire le
test or il faut couper se fondant et
voir si le coeur écoulant si le coeur et
coulon il est réussi
s'il est dur
il est raté ah là là à moins ça l'a
alors un an je crois qu'on peut dire
qu'il est réussi
alors le problème à la décharge de notre
restaurateur il est resté un petit peu
au chaud donc il a plu mais
effectivement il faut le servir chaud il
est tiède ou froid à l'intérieur et
coulant mais il est très bon et fort en
chocolat parce que vous avez le chocolat
je crois exactement c'est votre péché
mignon vous avez dont j'ai souvent le
chocolat c'est un problème de tablettes
de chocolat dans l'algérie est en
général un aspect très longtemps donc
oui c'est c'est un problème le chocolat
et le moelleux c'est aussi ce mélange
des textures quoi le coulant le lot et
c'est la douleur
en fait c'est la surprise aussi
justement de la découverte est ce que ce
sera ou non vraiment moelleux à
l'intérieur mais je trouve que voilà il
est parfaitement réussie en tout cas et
puis le chocolat ou le manger sous
toutes ses formes enfants mousse au
chocolat
on y annonce une tablette la vraie
tablette 70% à 81 79 ou au moins se
passe mais vous êtes du genre je
commence la tablette je vais jusqu'au
bout vous la mangez entièrement aubin
c'est ça ma difficulté à gabin sur du
mois il ya une tablette dans bureau donc
j'essaye j'essaye d'éviter dans
n'importe qui on va vous faire plaisir
on vous offre des champions ça sans
problème vous choisissez aussi les crues
parce que maintenant et le chocolat
péruviens et équatoriens brésilien et ye
brave à des casses à une chocolaterie ou
vraiment on peut aller voir plusieurs
crus différents exactement l inverse ça
aussi c'était vrai chocolatier
c'est-à-dire qu'ils qui vont eux mêmes
sur place qu'ils méritent aucun sens on
parle de traçabilité la manière avec
laquelle ces exploiter les personnes qui
travaillent aussi sur ses coûts
d'exploitation la et d'égout
extraordinairement aux différents en
fonction des pays le provenance du cacao
donc ça c'est enfin c'est assez
fascinant profitez-en bien car le
réchauffement de la planète pourrait
flinguer le caca ou malheureuses
profitez-en vous allez pouvoir le
terminer merci à bord berger d'avoir
participé à cette émission merci jean
pierre joly à vous tous de nous avoir
suivis et rendez vous bien sûr la
semaine prochaine pour un nouveau numéro
de politique à table et bien sûr on
remercie chez françoise qui nous a
préparé ce très bon boeuf bourguignon et
ce moelleux au chocolat très réussi
merci à vous tous
[Musique]